you're like dammit deal with it
it's not true this is the straw yes
there we go I Keshia chante for et
Canada hello
no drink your drink okay good night
shame to me he's sure same to me it
wasn't your fault though I didn't make
it please handed to me and then you two
pounced yeah
I am just waiting for me to take that in
my hand yeah I was ready when Jojo
rabbit one of the People's Choice Award
at tip mm-hmm it basically cemented you
in this film as a front-runner for award
season what was your reaction I didn't
know that you know once theater know
about that that the history of that
awarded with art films that had gone on
today so I found out about this award
and I said arts and won the Audience
Award but it's kind of like a
consolation prize isn't it the audience
of water you know it's the biggest film
and you know ever made in their psyche
most festivals I and the audience award
yeah you give that one as well but this
one yeah knows the award there's the one
to get yeah so I was really surprised
and pleased and the best thing about it
is because audiences are the they're the
people that make my films for more than
anyone and it's a fed the fact that they
they like there's enough of them like
the film for me to get their their award
was really special
yeah do you think people have a
preconceived notion of what this film is
about before they even watch it yeah I
feel like we all have preconceived
notions of what films are about based on
the poster or based on that you know the
sort of two sentences that are used to
describe films you know like this one of
you would say are sitting World War two
a lot of people were going
another world war ii film the difference
is this one is very different it's you
know I think it's telling the same story
and having and continuing that
conversation which needs to continue but
it's doing it in a way that's that I
think draws audiences in for a deeper
emotional experience and it's funny it's
very funny you playing Hitler is very
funny wasn't expecting it
yeah me neither to be like that are you
excited to work with Natalie Portman and
Thor and will we see an overweight Chris
Hemsworth would well I can't tell you no
that's it okay I mean I can tell the
it's that I am yes I am excited to work
with Natalie Portman yeah Emily
Portsmouth's
Department ports wasn't it Natalie
vitally important man mess yes whatever
sign it's so stoked to be working with
Natalia Portsmouth on the new film
theory perfect that's it
that's all I can tell you other than
yeah Chris will be in it
[Laughter]
[Music]
was it a tough sell to get you know
Scarlett Johansson and I mean just in
such an amazing cast and people together
for a film like this because when
someone told me about the film it was
like World War two it's sad - what was
you give me the expression that you had
been I'll be your friend or whoever I
was telling you since the film so I said
World War two - satires about this kid
who grows growing up he's in the Hitler
Youth
and yeah it's a kids movie it is it's
like PGE I was shook it I'm like what
kids can see this just cuz something is
a PG hey kids just cuz something the PG
doesn't mean that it's a kids maybe
alright what was stand by me but that
was different and a PG in the eighties
there like 47 f-bombs and what do kids
smoking and yet mean there was a
different time now PG me something else
but kids yeah kids what's question the
question is was it a tough sell ah well
I didn't say I didn't try and sell it
yeah that was what I was gonna say I
didn't really pitch this film anywhere
because it is a hard thing to pitch and
and it's not just the story but it's
it's the time that you're trying to
pitch his way there's some jokes and you
know people go
kind of jokes because I've been eighty
years into the Great Dictator but the
yeah the thing I don't wrote a script
that I was really confident with and I
felt was a really great script and I
sent them around and that was the pitch
I said look I've run my pitch for you
just read the script yeah and you know
do what you're paid for read scripts and
see what you think
thank you